it's an all-out war over impeachment the
White House telling Democrats to take a
hike because they're not going to comply
with their rigged inquiry and president
Trump's calling out the Democrats
tactics and the whistleblower they have
eviscerated the rules you have a man
named Schiff where I had a perfect phone
call with the president of Ukraine like
I mean perfect if people read it but
they don't read that they heard shifts
version of it he defrauded the American
public the whistleblower is a Democrat
strong Democrat and is working with one
of my opponents as a Democrat that I
might end up running against the whole
thing is a scam it's a fix this comes as
Joe Biden for the first time backing
impeachment he's already convicted
himself in full view of the world and
the American people Donald Trump has
violated his oath of office betrayed
this nation and committed impeachable
acts to preserve our Constitution our
democracy our basic integrity he should
be impeached by these words setting off
a Twitter battle with the president and
Donald Trump responding this way so
pathetic to see sleepy Joe Biden who
with his son hunter and to the detriment
of the American taxpayer has ripped off
at least two countries for millions of
dollars calling for my impeachment and I
did nothing wrong
Joe's failing campaign gave him no other
choice and Joe Biden hitting back thanks
for watching stop stonewalling the
Congress honor your oath respect the
Constitution and speaking of taxpayers
I've released 21 years of my tax returns
you all right so lot stuff happening
today one before we get to this whole
deal with this impeachment a lot of
breaking news on the coup front and on
the Ukraine front like for you to maybe
address some of these new documents show
that hunter Biden was not just paid
fifty thousand dollars a month
records show it was a hundred and sixty
six thousand dollars a month a month
hundred and sixty six hundred thousand
dollars a month Wow
it's a lot of money also the United
States knew that Ukraine was reopening
up and
into the Biden's in February so that
destroys the prequel Pro also not only
did the whistleblower he's a Democrat
and he works with someone running
against President Trump also a Democrat
he used to work for James clapper care
to respond to any of those things so in
other words the president was pressuring
the president of Ukraine even though the
Ukraine had already started
investigating Jessie it makes no sense
but I'm glad you're right you're I agree
right what's the president didn't know
what he was doing and that's why he was
doing no look I think the first thing to
address is this letter that came out
yesterday and the continual stonewalling
by the president in the White House this
is dangerous this is a constitutional
crisis he's trying to break the system
of our government Congress has the right
to impeach and inquire as to whether to
impeach her president and he's just
saying I'm not cooperating I'm not going
along then he attacks the whistleblower
the whistleblower is a Democrat the
whistleblower has said so far has been
corroborated and guess who corroborated
it Donald Trump and you know Trump right
now is spending I think it this week
he's already spent seven hundred
thousand dollars on ads he said well
immigration stirred up the base I'm
gonna stir up the base now with talk of
impeachment but you know it's what
strikes me is Mitch McConnell's playing
along oh this is a cool this is an
attempt to reverse the 2016 election
this is absurd this is a constitutional
crisis in which a president is acting as
an outlaw an outlaw Wow give him a lasso
I love when Democrats say oh he wants to
break the foundation of government but
then when you call for Nancy Pelosi to
actually take a vote and have them be
held accountable to go you guys get
mired down in procedure
you can't selectively care about
appropriate procedure what they have
come out and said the White House is we
want a vote to be held we want those
Democrats and Republicans who support
impeachment to be held accountable for
that decision this is a serious matter
they're agreeing they want the full
transcript of that Volcker desk
deposition and they're saying if you're
gonna do this you have to do it properly
now I get that Joe Biden needs this
really badly to be a headline he needs
the top of everybody's page when they go
to Google to be impeachment impeachment
impeachment because he doesn't
you talking about the economy he doesn't
want you talking about border security
he doesn't want any of the
accomplishments that this president has
put forth to be highlighted he doesn't
want it highlighted that he really
hasn't set forth an agenda and most
Democrats can't even name what positive
things he would do if he actually got
elected so he needs this story badly
unfortunately for him he's on tape doing
the exact quid pro quo stuff that he is
blaming President Trump for doing so you
know what hold the impeachment hearing
and let Biden in his son testify below
and then politically I think it was a
great tactic to say you know shove it
Democrats because let's go to court if
you guys want to Bews your authority as
a legislative branch the executive
branch can say you know what I'll see
you in court this drags it out past the
new year and it totally erodes any
attention the Democrats are gonna get
that are running for president and
that's why I think there is not a
constitutional crisis because there is
still a system in place and everybody
gets to use the system right and and you
and remember we've been hearing
constitutional crisis since before the
election even took place so that wears a
little bit thin and president Trump
relishes the fight so much that he just
wears down his opponents the thing for
Biden said he finally came out today was
a little bit more forceful but he's not
a pure messenger on this and he doesn't
really have a spokesperson who is able
to do it for him so there's no like he
is the vice president right if you think
back to when Obama was going after
george w bush about torture for all
those times who came out and defended it
was Dick Cheney right that that was the
proper place for Dick Cheney to be to be
able to defend Vice President Biden was
the vice president also he's now the
father of the somebody who was accused
or well there's allegations and there's
I didn't know the hundred and sixty-six
thousand dollars a month that is a lot
of moolah I mean that's not getting up
there but he doesn't have an effective
messenger outside of himself right
there's no echo chamber and the other
twenty twenty Democrats now they all say
they're for impeachment but nobody's
really defending the actual allegation
so I don't know if he needs somebody
there I say does he need his own Rudy Oh
somebody everybody needs it Rudy he's
actually mad at the DNC for not coming
to his defense hard enough Greg let's
listen to Donald Trump's a new sound on
Joe Biden you can react so Biden is
dropping like a rock
I don't think he's gonna make it I
didn't think he was gonna make it for a
long time I don't think he's gonna make
it and I guess this is one way he can do
it you know he didn't say that until
right now and he sees what's happening
to him I guess he's no longer at the
front-runner he's been hit and he's been
caught red-handed great hmm well you
know I don't believe this is about
actual impeachment right I wear what
they're trying to do is create a
quagmire process okay so that they can
warp public opinion which they're doing
so they can shake the confidence of
Republicans who support the president
which is happening I think and handicap
him with a whole big giant cloud a
headache for 2020 the reason why they're
doing this is not it it's because they
hate him because do this little do this
little experiment I wrote this stuff
down almost under the swear words
imagine a Democratic president doing
this in three years
uh sure in prison reform Democratic
president drawing down Wars because he's
stingy about blood and treasure you
uttering and record employment for women
and minorities growing median household
income eight point three percent to a
record sixty six thousand dollars
placing which restrictions on China for
suppressing Muslims that sounds like the
greatest Democratic president in history
definitely better than Obama he just
happens to be a Republican and he just
happens to be Donald Trump so it's all
about how much they hate the guy because
they should be embraced embracing his
policies I'm amazed how many Democrats
are upset about the Syrian decision when
they went basically it's always been
about American troops first making sure
they're safe not risking blood and
treasure so the thing is for me is like
I it drives me crazy that we take this
story seriously I'm not just a Fox host
Dana I'm a Fox viewer okay you know that
got rid of the hair Club yeah I don't
just I don't just I'm not just president
I'm a client yes well I'm a Fox News
client so it drives me nuts that we take
seriously this narrative this conjoined
narrative from the from the Democrats in
the media CNN the New York Times
Washington Post shift they must be
laughing their asses off when we
to their tune this is such a joke it's
such a joke it's all designed to win an
election
that's all it is let me just say though
don't you agree the greatest Democratic
president ever da Mitrano he switch
parties again well you know he's never
been in he's never been in a party look
we don't know he's like a great you
can't deny anything
yes I can what like prison reform the
economy unemployment you leave me cereal
in the manufacturing sector how about
those coal mines no but let me just what
about the coal miners here's the thing I
threat to you he's a threat to the media
he's a threat to the Democrats he's the
richest skunk in the garden party and no
one knows how to get him out of there
you are a fox viewer yes and I throw the
shoe at Fox at times is that right yes
only when you're talking say you can't
say the people ignore what you can see
for yourself with your own eyes exactly
like the transcript is president who
released the letter says basically I was
using American military aid to extort a
foreign country that's the dirt I'm not
you just pull the ship this is what
people who work at boxer so it's a
difference of life throw the chute for I
there's so much partisanship around the
judgment